good clinical practice or gcp
is an international ethical and
scientific quality standard for
designing
conducting recording and reporting
clinical trials that involve the
participation of human subjects
regardless of whether a clinical trial
is a large multi-center study in
patients
or a small clinical pharmacological
study in healthy subjects
the relevant gcp standard should be
followed by the sponsoring company of
the healthcare product
the investigators the ethics committees
and any clinical research
organizations companies undertaking a
clinical trial should develop written
procedures for implementing gcp
such procedures may include but are not
limited to the following
investigator site selection regulatory
document collection
review and submission financial
disclosure
investigator site initiation
investigational product distribution and
tracking
clinical monitoring of investigator site
investigator site closeout
safety reporting quality assurance
audits
required documents for study master file
and document retention
vendor qualification and oversight for
example contract research organization
an indemnity compensation and insurance
prior to the gcp guidance document
developed by the international
conference on harmonization
i ch different jurisdictions had
different guidelines relating to the
conduct of clinical trials
with the introduction of ich gcp the
conduct of clinical trials globally has
become more uniform and practicable
today the implementation of ich good
clinical practice in most jurisdictions
is reasonably similar
and the vast majority of the regulations
are the same
despite the effort of ich there still
exists some local differences
for example the us no longer adheres to
the declaration of helsinki in its
entirety
because the declaration considers
placebo-controlled trials unethical in
cases where an active drug is available
new privacy regulations in the eu and
the financial disclosure requirements in
the u.s are also making the clinical
trial landscape more complicated
healthcare product developers should
therefore work to ich
in the context of local regulations
the regulations guidance and industry
standards that make up good clinical
practice
are intended to provide assurance that
the rights safety and well-being of
clinical trial subjects are protected
gcp is also intended to assure that the
research yields quality scientific data
fundamentally good clinical practice
requires
oversight of the local ethics committees
verification of the investigators
qualifications
a study protocol investigators brochure
informed consent
and the documentation that is essential
for undertaking a clinical trial
monitoring of the clinical trial
submission of reports and maintenance of
records
and the ich gcp lays out the
responsibilities of the ethics
committees
sponsors and investigators the core
principles of ich
good clinical practice are presented
below
first clinical trials should be
conducted in accordance with the ethical
principles that have their origin in the
declaration of helsinki
and that are consistent with gcp and the
applicable regulatory requirements
second before a trial is initiated
foreseeable risks and inconveniences
should be weighed against the
anticipated benefit for the individual
trial subject in society
a trial should be initiated and
continued only if the anticipated
benefits justify the risks
third the rights safety and well-being
of the trial subjects
are the most important considerations
and should prevail over interests of
science and society
fourth the available non-clinical and
clinical information
on an investigational product should be
adequate to support the proposed
clinical trial
fifth clinical trials should be
scientifically sound and described in a
clear
detailed protocol
sixth a trial should be conducted in
compliance with the protocol that has
received prior institutional review
board or the independent ethics
committee approval
seventh the medical care and medical
decisions given to subjects should
always be the responsibility
of a qualified physician or when
appropriate of a qualified dentist
eighth each individual involved in
conducting a trial should be qualified
by education
training and experience to perform his
or her respective tasks
ninth freely given informed consent
should be obtained from every subject
prior to clinical trial participation
tenth all clinical trial information
should be recorded
handled and stored in a way that allows
its accurate reporting
interpretation and verification eleventh
the confidentiality of records that
could identify subjects should be
protected
respecting the privacy and
confidentiality rules in accordance with
the applicable regulatory requirements
12. investigational products should be
manufactured
handled and stored in accordance with
applicable good manufacturing practice
gmp they should be used in accordance
with the approved protocol
and finally 13. systems with procedures
that assure the quality of every aspect
of the trial should be implemented
in summary gcp helps protect the rights
safety and well-being of clinical trial
subjects and assures quality scientific
data
you